live local now at six o'clock the
manager of the dottie's killed and a
suspect on the run we have the
surveillance video
preventing suicides the father's advice
to parents after losing his son and part
4 of our survival in the desert series
what common item you probably have in
your house that can help you in case of
an emergency
this year's nfl schedule is being
released right now chris matthews with
what it is looking like for our raiders
warmer today in the 70s but the real
heat comes very soon we'll show you when
all coming up
now this is eight news now live at six
live local now
video showing the moments before a
woman's murder the manager of a dottie's
casino run over and killed the hunt now
underway for the driver of this stolen
suv that's video first shared with our
eight news now i-team good evening i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis that
manager now identified as 60-year-old
alicia gibbelini now right now police
are searching for that driver believed
to be in a stolen car the i-team's david
charns has more from the scene
video shared with the 8 news now i-team
reveals the moments before the manager
at this dotties was run over and killed
a nearby business sharing the video in
hopes of finding the driver this witness
asking us not to identify them not even
having
no kind of empathy or anything to stop
and check on her or anything like that
the video shows a person believed to be
the manager following that driver to
this stolen mercedes suv outside of
dottie's near flamingo and jones
officials identifying that manager
thursday as 60-year-old alicia gabalina
police say she was chasing the man
suspected of stealing a customer's purse
she probably didn't think that he was
going to run her over but you know
some people in the heat at the moment
they want to try and help somebody else
out and stuff like bad stuff like this
happen police say the driver then pulled
out a gun putting the car in reverse and
hitting a parked vehicle the driver then
ran over the manager as he drove off
investigators confirming that mercedes
suv was reported stolen over the weekend
it could be anyone we don't even know
how he looks like paulina cardenas works
nearby never gotten this bad like
personally from what i've been working
here it's never been this bad
until yesterday other businesses in this
plaza putting out flowers marking the
spot where this happened they hope this
driver is caught quickly we did reach
out to dotties today and they had no
comments we're near flamingo and jones
i'm david charns live local now
there is a vigil being held right now
for amari nicholson the two-year-old's
body found one year ago today we're
going to take a live look at that vigil
police say 28 year old terrell rhodes
punched the child after the child had
urinated on himself they also say rhodes
hid nicholson's body near the emerald
suites on twain and paradise
rhodes trial is supposed to begin in
august denise
well nearly every day we get a reminder
about just how big an issue mental
health is all across the world in fact
today ashley judd revealing to the world
that her mother naomi judd shot and
killed herself mental health crosses all
barriers in affecting people at all
levels of our society in fact just
yesterday we told you about an apparent
murder-suicide near baker in this case a
mother killing her baby and then turning
the gun on herself
and one local father has made it his
life's mission to help cut down on the
number of people taking their own lives
reggie burton knows the issue all too
well his son avery died by suicide
victoria saha joining us now with more
on the story and also advice that burton
has for other parents
yesterday's burton is a parent who knows
too well the heartache he says this is
such a sensitive topic but an important
one that needs to be discussed so
families can recognize the silent cries
for help
graduation a momentous time for students
and everyone around them sometimes that
celebration is just a precursor to a
stressful event burton's son avery had
the world ahead of him in may of 2017 he
graduated from unlv with the hopes of
becoming a doctor and then he realized
it wasn't what he actually wanted or at
least he didn't think he wanted
and that's what spurred the major
depressive episode just two months later
that depressive state led avery to take
his own life so this is a kid that was
used to fixing
problems but this was just one problem
that he couldn't solve burton says
although his family was aware that avery
was going through a tough time he says
avery was very good at hiding the extent
of it which he says is a common thing
among those struggling with mental
illness families default to love they
want to try to love the problem away and
what we need to try to understand and
the lesson we learned is that love's not
enough and experts say it's okay for
family and friends to take that first
step to start the conversation having a
really heart-to-heart conversation and
if there's any notice any change that
the parents notice that is different
from their norm
then you know that's that's an area of
concern and certainly needs to be
addressed a conversation that can
hopefully turn the outcome around the
surviving family members my heart goes
out to them because they have a lot of
questions and not a lot of answers
since avery's death burton says he
started a foundation in his son's name
aimed at helping those struggling you
can find more about the avery burton
foundation on our website at
8newsnow.com ryan
victoria thank you for that the u.s
postal service is investigating after a
mail carrier was apparently robbed
happened this morning near twain and
arville west of i-15 there's the
location we're told the mail carrier was
not injured usps says it's investigative
arm the postal inspection service is
looking into the incident and what
exactly happened
a las vegas woman is accused of starving
her three horses to the point that one
of them had to be put down metro says
her melinda rocha neglected to feed or
care for the horses an arrest report
shows they were very underweight it also
says one of them was seen eating its own
feces rocha's next court date is set for
the beginning of august
weather now yesterday we did not even
reach
60 degrees today of course we warmed up
and of course we had this too yesterday
a car damaged by a dust devil this is
this was a
rancho and lone mountain right near
santa fe station we know there was a
dust devil because you the viewers sent
us a great video of it look at that that
fence just slamming into this viewer's
car so we thank you so much for sending
us those pictures that dust devil most
likely had gusts up to 60 or more
elsewhere that we had gusts mainly
around 40 miles per hour not the case
outside right now though look at your
current wind speeds at this hour less
than 10 miles per hour 74 degrees today
so we warmed it up quite a bit and
humidity at 20 percent here weather
headlines last cool day
today because after that things really
start to warm up tomorrow in fact our
first 100 degree day of the year is in
the 8 day forecast next week though get
this winds again
but a cooling trend we're going to show
you just how much we'll drop those
temperatures for next week after
reaching our first 100 that's all coming
up in your most accurate forecast
in just a few minutes
state attorney general aaron ford is
warning nevadans to keep an eye out for
scammers who are pretending to represent
banks he says his office has been
getting reports from nevada-based banks
about these scams so they're putting
forward a few tips to protect yourself
and here's one of them you can set up
what's called multi-factor
authentication that's when a website
calls or it'll text your phone after you
log in we have more tips for you on our
website at 8newsnow.com
well the nfl schedule release day it's
really a big deal people study it yeah
and now it's become like an event teams
and their fans finding out where and
when they're going to be playing for the
next season sports director chris
matthews joining us now in studio with
more on the raiders schedule chris yeah
you get your plans your tickets airfare
all that ready now it's becoming a big
big day for the nfl and its fans they
now can start making plans where will
they go will they wear coats or jackets
maybe not where will the raiders play
well the raiders will open their season
on the road september 11th at the
chargers it'll be a 125 kickoff right
here on channel 8. it'll be the eighth
time the two teams have opened their
seasons against each other now raiders
home opener is the following week at
allegion stadium september 18th against
the arizona cardinals and again 125
kickoff right here on channel 8 your
network home for the las vegas raiders
hey we don't have to time to really run
through the entire schedule a few
breakout games though always kind of fun
and interesting here the raiders will
play one monday night game against
kansas city thursday against the rams
that is week 14 then the following week
it's december 18th sunday night here in
las vegas against the patriots on
christmas eve against the steelers the
writers will visit the steel city prime
time game on nfl network while you can
catch out this entire schedule go to our
website eight newsnow dot com and check
it out by the way nine games possibly
ten will be here on channel 8 this
season coming up in about 15 minutes
john treach is with raiders tight end
darren waller who is holding his
foundation fundraiser waller and some of
his raiders teammates what are they
saying about the schedule release back
over to you guys denise
all right chris thanks well ranchers in
east central nevada